Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Emily Broad Lieb, who is a clinical professor
of law and faculty director for Harvard Law
School's food law and Policy Clinic.
It's so great having you on today, Emily.
Really appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Thanks so much.
I'm so glad to be here.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, let's just start with
a little history.
Many of us are familiar with with food labels
in general and also expiration dates, Best
Buy, Sell, Buy, et cetera.
What's the sort of history of that?
When did it start?
Why did it start?
Speaker 3: Mm-Hmm.
So we see kind of this modern landscape of,
you know, these labels on most food products
really taking shape in the 70s.
And at that time, it was really consumers
were pushing companies and saying that they
wanted to know about the freshness of their
products.
So, you know, if you think about where we
were at that time, it was sort of starting
after like post-World War Two, people are
getting more further away from where their
food is produced, buying more things in the
grocery store.
And people said, if I'm not part of the farm
and getting it directly from a farm, how will
I know how fresh it is?
Right?
And that's when we we saw a lot of activity
in terms of voluntary use of these labels
on the part of companies.
Speaker 1: Now there was also in that period
of time in like the 20 years preceding the
70s, there was a move away from most of the
things that the grocery store are ingredients
to really like the food product, right?
Something that that's manufactured and sent
that.
And is that also part of why we started to
see those markings that like with a banana?
By looking at it, you can mostly tell what
is the status of this banana?
Whereas with some of these products, it might
be less clear.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's totally right.
So, you know, and I think even today in, you
know, fast forward to now, where there's their
labels on lots of products, a lot of states
require them, but it's primarily on packaged
foods because I think there's a sense that,
you know, banana and apple, you know, a food,
a food that you can pick up and hold in that
sort of in its raw form that people can really
make their own judgments about how fresh it
is and how spoiled how close it is to being
spoiled.
And it's really packaged foods that you see
these labels on because people don't really
know they can't open it up in the store and
smell it right there.
Speaker 1: So there's best if used by their
sell by there's a straight up expiration date
that sometimes is there.
These things presumably mean different things,
right?
Speaker 3: One would think, actually, that's
one of the biggest issues is that consumers
sort of look at them and think these labels
must be telling me different things.
But in fact, you know, most there's no law
that really regulates what those different
terms mean.
There's no, you know, there's no law defining
sell-by as compared to use by or expires on
right now.
In fact, there's no federal law regulating
date labels at all.
So the federal government, with a very small
exception of infant formula, has not required
anything.
And then in the states that have requirements,
they use them very interchangeably.
So I think that's one of the places where
we got really interested because consumers
are misled.
They they they think that they're, you know,
that they're seeing two different labels and
that they mean something different.
But there's not there's not any evidence that
that's the case.
Speaker 1: Well, so so I mean, if I see as
the common man, if I see sell buy, it suggests
to me it should be sold by that date, but
it's still pretty good for some period of
time beyond that.
Best, if used by says it, it should.
To me, it should be consumed by that day.
But you're saying it's not actually.
There's not actually an infrastructure that
guarantees that.
That's what I'm being told.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's totally right.
And you know, as we talk about why, how this
can be fixed, I do think there is a piece
of drawing on what consumers think that they're
reading and reducing the number of labels
and really drawing on like what consumers
already are understanding.
But just making that the case so that consumers
aren't, you know, aren't being confused about
it
Speaker 1: with something like, I mean, when
I first really started thinking about the
value of some of these labels is when I saw,
for example, an expiration date on salt.
And you know, when we think about salt, it's
like salt have been around for billions of
years.
It's just sort of naturally occurring.
And what does it mean if salt expires?
Does that have any meaning at all?
Why does salt expire?
Speaker 3: Right?
I agree with your same vinegar.
Similarly, it's right vinegar.
Now it has vinegar, does some other thing
bottled water, you know?
And I think people are trying to deal with
this cognitive dissonance by making up some
reason that the label so I hear people say,
Oh, what?
Oh, the label on bottled water is like when
the plastic is going to leach into the water.
I mean, that is there's no that is not happening
or if it is, the date is not the date of which
that happens.
You know, I think you're right that there
are a lot of food products that it doesn't
it doesn't seem.
Very clear why a label, a date label would
be needed on them, except that consumers have
just come to expect them on so many products,
and I've actually talked to people who have
said when I pick something up at the store
that doesn't have a date label on it, I'm
not sure what to do.
So, you know, again, I think in some of our
early work we thought, Well, maybe we should
just remove the label on foods where it's
really meaningless.
And I think that gets a lot of we get a lot
of pushback from consumer groups on that.
So we're really thinking, how can we take
what we have and make it work better and make
it align better and be less misleading?
You know, knowing that in some cases we are
where we are and we can't kind of completely
overhaul the system.
Speaker 1: The if we want to apply like a
corporate profit motive to this one could
imagine you could have foods that are safe
for much longer than the dates say.
But maybe the manufacturer is worried there
could be reputational damage because it might
not taste quite as good or whatever the case
may be.
How much of that is a factor in these labels?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
I mean, that is it's a really big factor,
especially if you think about where we are
right now, which is some states require dates
on certain foods.
There's a quite a just, you know, huge variation
in what food states require labels on and
then what you can do after the label.
So that leaves a lot up to the manufacturer
as far as like what words to use the science
or if there is any science behind how they're
setting that date.
And of course, for companies, they want you
to eat their food when it's going to taste
the best.
Right?
So or even more cynical version that people
say a lot is, you know, is it that they just
want you to throw it away and buy more?
And I don't think there's necessarily evidence
of that, but there is evidence and companies
would say this outright that, you know, they
want to set a label when their product, they
think, will taste the best and they want to
leave some wiggle room for the fact that you
might not put your yogurt in the refrigerator
right away and that, you know, so they're
kind of being conservative even on that date
that they're setting
Speaker 1: when it comes to food waste.
You know, we've talked for so long on this
program about you got a portion of food that
is just wasted on the field, so to speak.
It already is sort of like by the time it
would get to the supermarket, it might not
look so good.
So you lose some there, you lose food due
to spoilage and you lose food due to expiration
dates.
And a question that's often asked is shouldn't
that all be donated somewhere?
And one of the reasons that sometimes given
for why it's not is if you donate stuff to
a food pantry beyond the expiration date.
One.
Are you sending the message that people who
need to go to a food pantry are deserving
of expired food, right?
And sort of like the PR issue with that, but
also the concern of if someone gets sick and
it's beyond an expiration date, is the donor
potentially legally liable?
So are those and are there other ways in which
this is actually preventing dealing with an
issue like hunger?
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah.
I think you're spot on.
So I would say as far as the first point,
this sort of stigma point about, is this bad
food?
Are we essentially saying like, we're going
to give bad food to people right that are
that are accepting donated food on that piece?
What our approach has been is to say, if you
really standardize the labels to have one
label that's really clearly about food, the
small handful of foods that actually increase
at risk after the date, then everyone can
be clear in their own households.
And then we wouldn't donate those foods.
We're not we shouldn't be donating anything
that actually is riskier after the date.
And then if you have a separate standard label
that's really telling people for all of these
foods, you can keep eating it as long as it
smells.
OK, tastes OK.
You know, this is just totally an estimate
of freshness.
Then I would say, I mean, those should be
able to be sold.
They should be able to be donated.
People should feel free to use them.
People should swap them whatever it is.
So I think, you know, to me, a law that says
that they only can be donated but not sold.
Would you know, would it make sense because
it would increase that stigma?
And I'll say one, you know, pure country that's
done.
A really nice job of this is the U.K. where
they have used by is the standard label on
food that becomes riskier after the date.
That's before is the standard label on food
that is labeled just for freshness.
And then they've done actual campaigns with
consumers.
They had one last earlier this year that was
like look, smell, taste, don't waste.
And the whole campaign was really to let people
know if you see best before labels on it,
there's no way that there's no scientific
way to make those accurate, and there's no
risk after the date.
It's really just about your preference and
your mouth, and it got and then they make
it very clear those could be donated.
They can be sold at a discount.
You can still eat them, you can still serve
them.
No one's going to get sick.
And so I think again, there's there's like
a very clear roadmap for how we could improve
on this and and in a way that makes it not
just for.
You know, for for donation and give away,
but also for everyone to save dollars.
Speaker 1: There's a whole other kind of category
of food labels.
These include certified organic, all natural,
no preservatives.
No added sugar.
Whole grains only, you know, we could kind
of go down the list and different ones mean
different things.
Are any of these other than organic actually
regulated terms in any way that have a set
meaning every time they are used?
Speaker 3: So it's a hard question, because
there's truly so many of those labels.
Yeah.
Our eyes like what?
So it is, so to speak.
Ego labels like organic that really relate
to like the the way that they're grown and
produced in the environmental side, organic
is the only one.
There was legislation passed around bioengineered
label, which would be foods that are genetically
modified.
You label that will also be regulated on the
health side.
There are some that are that are regulated.
For example, if you want to say that a food
is healthy.
Oh, right.
But they're also thought that aren't that
heavily regulated.
So imagine that it sort of depends on the
label.
But I should say, you know these a lot of
those faulted the Food and Drug Administration
to enforce them, like there's thousands and
thousands of products with thousands and thousands
of labels.
And I think I think most people in this space
present party good.
It would say that, you know, there might be
labels on there that aren't actually being
enforced because FDA just doesn't have the
capacity to get to all of them and make sure
that they're
Speaker 1: at one point there was this heart
healthy label, which many of us would be familiar
from oats, Quaker Oats.
But it was basically, if I recall correctly,
at least in its initial version, based on
the amount of fat.
And so you had very strange products, including
at one point I think it was like the equivalent
of some kind of Fruit Roll-Up type candy,
which I think qualified for the label based
on its absence of fat.
But it's not really something that we would
think.
I mean, it's a highly processed its candy,
essentially.
And so it was like this what does this really
mean?
Speaker 3: Right, right.
Right now, I think you're right, and I think
this has been a critique of a lot of those
labels healthy, you know, heart healthy, low
fat, whatever.
And there are disqualifying levels of other
nutrients.
But sugar, which really people weren't as
worried about, right?
You know, in the 80s when a lot of these labeling
and early '90s.
So now you have these bizarre outcomes where
there's like no disqualifying level of sugar
for all of these health related claims.
You know, I think this is something that FDA
has been supposedly working on.
Hopefully, it will know get around to really
updating some of those labels because I think
they are really misleading for consumers.
And I think today sugar is really one of the
most concerning ingredients and products in
terms of just the, you know, where we are
as a country.
Speaker 1: So what are they on sugar labeling
like?
What are some of the issues, it seems?
I mean, some that come to me off the top.
My head is sometimes it will say no sugar,
but it has various sirups which are, you know,
arguably not different than sugar from a health
standpoint.
Sometimes you will see things like sweetened
with beet sugar, as if that's really different
than cane sugar or regular sugar.
When it's unclear, there really is a difference.
I mean, it seems sort of like the the gluten
free label on an apple where it's like, yes,
it's gluten free, but is that really actionable
and relevant in any way?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I totally agree.
Yeah, evaporated cane evaporated.
Cane sirup is one you will see, and I still
see it.
And I think, you know, FDA has said it's not
allowed again.
They don't have the capacity to enforce all
of them, so consumers pay the price of that.
You know, I think that there's both responsibility
on the part of the FDA and potentially on
Congress to really beef up the resources so
that those can be enforced and evaporating.
Cane sirup is literally sugar.
It is what everyone would think of as sugar.
And yet, you know, again, it will say no sugar,
and it will have that on a product and
Speaker 1: yeah, to other specific ones that
I want to ask about.
So organic is actually a regulated term with
a specific meaning about about the how it's
grown or whatever when it comes to all natural.
What is important for people to understand
about whether all natural has any meaning
whatsoever?
Speaker 3: Mm-Hmm.
Great question.
No one can answer that question because there's
no definition really from the Food and Drug
Administration for all natural.
So there's been a huge, huge amount of litigation,
particularly in California, which has really
nice laws that are very supportive towards
consumers.
It's just a lot of litigation around a paddock
with an all natural claim and then plaintiffs
consumers saying that they bought the product
and then realize afterwards there were certain
processing elements or it was ultra processed
or it included, you know, gene edited or genetically
engineered materials that people would think
don't seem natural.
And you know, there's there's I would say
for now, I treat that claim as if I just ignore
it completely.
I would say that mean that is meaningless
at the moment.
And I think again, there's there's a big question
mark as to if and when we will, we will.
See, the FDA come out with a real definition
that can give consumers a little more confidence
in that claim.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to ask about,
and I know we're now getting like a couple
levels removed from where we started homeopathic
products, herbal products, some supplements,
cetera where they say statements have not
been evaluated by the FDA, et cetera.
We've all seen that type of thing.
What are the concerns and sort of what is
in that general space that consumers should
be aware of when looking at those products?
Speaker 3: You now here's a couple of steps
from my bailiwick, and they're there, even
if I said already that there's a lot of claims
on foods that either FDA hasn't yet defined
like natural, they don't really have a great
definition or where there is a very clear
definition, but they just don't have the resources
to enforce.
Once you get into supplements, you know, herbal
things, etc., it's even more so that way.
I mean, a lot of people in the food space
will call that really the Wild West in terms
of the in terms of the the level of both laws
and enforcement.
So I think it's it's a really difficult area.
I think there's a lot of folks calling for
more regulation.
They're, you know, making sure both that there's
really two concerns.
One is when you buy a supplement is what's
in there actually what it says it is right
back in is are the claims about what it can
do for your health.
Validated in any way.
And I think on both ends of that, it's a really
big question mark and it's hard for the companies
that are, you know, trying to do it well and
trying to do a good job because I think they
will probably like more enforcement so that
they, you know there that people will have
more trust in that space.
Speaker 1: Yeah, without a doubt.
Emily Broad Broadleaf is a clinical professor
of law and faculty director for Harvard Law
School's Food Law and Policy Clinic.
Really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 3: Great talking to you.
Thanks.